[Musik]
ein wunderschöner morgen erwartet uns
hier in unserer kleinen süßen minecraft
und meine lieben freunde wir werden
heute endlich mal wieder eine ganze
episode lang in die höhe gehen die wir
vor einigen folgen hinter in der wüste
entdeckt haben sie sehen allerdings
bereits dass ich mich schon in meiner
kiste befindet das hat nämlich erstens
damit zu tun dass ich mir einen
diamanten hell machen wollte dass wir
nämlich in die kommentare geschrieben
damit ich das nicht vergessen also danke
dir auf jeden fall an der stelle und
diesen diamanten helm werde ich auch
direkt mal hier vorne verzaubern ich
hoffe dass wir eine geile verzauberung
da drauf kriegen und wie
nur haltbarkeit kommen
perfekter das bringt absolut gar nichts
ist aber auch egal wir setzen uns sind
trotzdem einfach mal auf dann sind wir
auf jeden fall wieder komplett
ausgerüstet und was sich auch noch ganz
kurz machen wollte was wir nämlich und
in die kommentare geschrieben wurde war
luca und können jetzt ja oben in den
leuchtturm einfach mal ein lagerfeuer
hinsetzen
ja okay dann bleibt leben dann ist das
jetzt einfach unser ballonfahrer hier
oben ist natürlich auch blöd dass die
ich oben jetzt darum spawnen können
allerdings setzt sich jetzt einfach mal
ein lagerfeuer hin und dann ist es
zumindest für unseren kopf so als wenn
hier wirklich dann rauch aufsteigen
würde von daher ist das eigentlich ganz
nett und ich glaube bei nacht sieht man
ja auch die beleuchtung eines
lagerfeuers von unten so ein bisschen
das deutet sich hier schon leicht an von
daher sollte der ballon auf weihnachten
ein bisschen eis aussehen wird auch in
die kommentare geschrieben luca unter
dem ballon beleuchten dann leuchtet er
bei nacht aber habt ihr schon mal einen
beleuchteten heißluftballon gesehen ich
habe glaube ich noch keinen gesehen und
da habe ich mir gedacht mensch der so
einfach so bleiben ist muss auch nicht
alles immer beleuchtet sein allerdings
dass man ganz gute tipps wie ich mich
auf unsere höhlen expedition vorbereitet
[Musik]
so meine damen und herren wir verlassen
unsere inselgruppe hier vorne und lassen
auch die willicher insel hinter uns
verlassen die denkmäler für die kuh und
das schaf hinter uns und wir lassen auch
den leuchtturm das portal stellt und
ganz am horizont taucht im neuen
luftballon hinter uns denn wir bewegen
uns nun in richtung wüsten höhle und da
habe ich mich gerade die ganze zeit
ausgerüstet ich hoffe dass wir ankommen
werden bevor die sonne untergeht ihr
seht auch schon unten in einem inventar
in meiner leiste dass ich dem team
mitgenommen habe und ein feuerzeug er
fragte jetzt wahrscheinlich ein oder
andere luca warum nimmst du dir und ein
feuerzeug mit wild zu etwa irgend etwas
in die luft sprengen es wäre gelogen
wenn ich nein sagen würde denn wir
wurden die kommentare geschrieben luca
du musst dich mal an den keepern rechnen
allerdings
wurde mir dann auch gesagt hey doch
einen keeper kopf oder irgendwie so dass
mit dem ganzen aber nicht gerecht werden
weil das wäre unsinnig und das wäre
verschwenderisch weil ich ja nicht die
krippenfeier so wie ich beispielsweise
das schaf gefeiert habe oder die kuh
denen ich ja ein denkmal gebaut habe in
form eines kopfes auf diese samt inseln
deswegen habe ich mir gedacht ich
sprenge einfach in kryta in die luft und
zahle es so mit den keepern reinheim
nicht nein und das ist so ein bisschen
meine rache an die kripo oft von ihnen
überrascht wurde auch durch fieber
getötet wurde immer durch die explosion
irgendwas kaputt gegangen ist und jetzt
habe ich den ganzen krieg an das einfach
mal heim dadurch dass ich mir einfach
jetzt hinter mitgenommen habe und ein
feuerzeug und in der höhle dann
hoffentlich den einen oder anderen
kritiker sehen sollte hoffe tun ich gar
nicht reden wir sehen uns wieder wenn
ich bei der höhle bin und da sind wir
auch schon angekommen meine lieben
freunde ich lass das brötchen jetzt
einfach mal hier vorne stehen
beziehungsweise ich dass es hier stehen
ich habe ziemlich auch noch ein bisschen
holz mit am start ich habe mich komplett
gut ausgerüstet von daher brauche ich
jetzt noch gar nicht schlafen geht es
sieht schon sehr schön hier vorne mit
dem sonnenuntergang
allerdings würde ich sagen wir bewegen
uns nun jetzt in die höhle
perfekt wir starten natürlich direkt mit
dem abbau von kohle denn meine lieben
freunde ich habe bisher den letzten
folgen mitbekommen mir fehlt ein wenig
kohle zu hause und man kann nie genug
kohle haben
es hat auch schon jesus damals gesagt
wir bewegen uns weiter in die höhle rein
und bevor ich hier vorne das eisen abbau
werde ich mir hier erst mal ganz kurz
mal ein crafting table hinsetzen denn
ich habe leider vergessen mein schild
mitzunehmen und das halt in meine
schwache hand zu nehmen damit ich mich
verteidigen kann gegen die monster
deswegen kann man einmal ganz kurzen
schild gemacht und ich werde mir auch
ganz kurz auch einen wassereimer machen
denn wenn ich in lava fallen sollte es
auf jeden fall von essentieller
notwendigkeit dass ich mich dort nicht
verbrenne und daher nun weiter hier rein
und auch erstmal hier vorne direkt die
kohle mitnehmen und dann hier vorne um
die kurve herum wo wir direkt wieder
kohle am start haben und hier unten auch
noch ein bisschen reisen bzw es geht
noch weiter nicht leuchtet das jetzt
erst mal aus wir haben hier auch noch
gold hier vorne haben wir eine menge
gremmel das darf auf jeden fall nicht
runterfallen bisher haben wir noch kein
einziges monster
hier entdeckt allerdings auch noch keine
diamanten oder sehr sehr wertvoller
ärzte und die spitzhacke kaputtgegangen
von daher mal wieder fix die crafting
menschen nehmen und eine neue spitzhacke
kräften und dann gehen wir jetzt auch
mal ganz kurz den anderen gang hier
runter hier ist allerdings
lover von daher wissen wir dass wird
diese beiden gänge definitiv nicht mehr
benötigen von daher setze ich jetzt
einfach mal so einen kleinen cobblestone
turm hin und hier vorne auch damit werde
ich das jetzt mal andeuten dass wir da
auf jeden fall nicht mehr lang laufen
müssen von daher können wir uns jetzt
hier auf erstmal konzentrieren er war
der kleine rundlauf deswegen nehme ich
hier mal eben ganz fix noch die beiden
eisenköck
[Musik]
jetzt laufen wir mal rüber in diese
richtung hier
wir haben unser erstes ziel
wir haben unser erstes ziel freund ich
habe ja drei tnt mit dabei hier sind
allerdings noch ein paar andere monster
hier vorne habe ich gerade auch noch ein
skelett in die aktive fehlen
dies hat auch hier vorne ist es
der zweite übernehmen
freunde an die kripo die rache
doch warum wie kann das sein
und leute zwei macsteel
das kommt nicht die welt aber ich habe
nur noch zwei tnt
mission zu ende
als wenn ich einfach nicht
ich habe nur noch ein tnt
ich konzentriert
das gläschen vorne gesehen allerdings
schränkt vier haben der kommt auch
runter jetzt freuen
warum stellst du licht sprachenlernen
hatte ich werde mir jetzt erst mal mit
meinem eimer das wasser weg nehmen so
dass wir hier unten auch so ein bisschen
mehr klar schiff haben und dann kommen
wir jetzt erst mal gucken was sich hier
fordert
[Musik]
das ist das ist ein schacht diese höhle
das schon wieder
viel
größer als
[Musik]
das geht ja nicht er ab
was geht denn hier ab leute
ich dachte wir gehen ganz entspannt
ganz entspannt gehen wie eine höhle
dachte ich mir und jetzt sind wir schon
wieder in einem
jetzt
auch leute geht es raus
hier geht raus
ich bin draußen
[Musik]
ich wollte ja nicht raus ich platz ihr
hier oben neben unserem höhleneingang
schon mal eine truhe wo ich so ein paar
sachen rein packe die ich vorerst
erstmal nicht benötige wie
beispielsweise so viele bruchstein
brauche ich wirklich nicht dann noch
hier den bogen den brauche ich generell
eigentlich nicht das freut zwar benötige
ich auch nicht mehr da ich eh kein thema
habe und die kohle nämlich nur noch mit
falls wir noch ein paar fakten lassen
möchte und jetzt start
und ich frage mich warum immer meine
richtung kaputt geht dann
wenigstens infektionen drin freunde also
wieder zurück in die höhle und ich hoffe
mal dass wir relativ zeitnah in schacht
finden werden ich werde jetzt auch das
reisen um eine kontrolle kommt wieder
runter
[Musik]
ich werde jetzt erstmal das eisen hier
lassen und generell nicht darauf
konzentrieren den schacht wieder zu
finden die kohle lassen wir auch was man
hier davon haben wir der ob ich genug im
schacht wer hat das geile welt nein ich
hatte eigentlich ein deal mit der spinne
ich hoffe einfach dass wir im schacht
vielleicht ein paar diamanten finden
dass wir auf jeden fall wild glaube der
war hier vorne wenn wir jetzt links
laufen dann hier hoch moment wartet hier
dann wieder rechts beim um die kurve und
jetzt links ich habe den schacht
gefunden
doch direkt zombies am start und
generell wieder so eine große fläche wo
es jeder ecke
wieder ein neues monster kommen kann ich
werde mich jetzt allerdings erstmal
nicht auf diese ecken konzentrieren hier
ist ja auch eine menge wasser und wir
haben auch gesehen dass die heute teils
unter wasser ist können wir nämlich hier
auch schon hoch gucken und sehen hier
vorne auch schon über grund
das war's
ich glaube das war der kleinste schafft
den ich je in minecraft gesehen habe
hier
[Musik]
wo kommen die dann immer her wo kommen
diese blöden kiefer der immerhin ihr
geht unser schacht auf jeden fall
[Musik]
hier geht's auf jeden fall weiter
meine lieben freunde
wir scheuen allerdings keine gefoult
haben
nicht ganz fit und
leute 2 max hirt und läutet einig hier
[Musik]
und heute schreibe ich hier
ich sagte
meine frau liebt mich
verliebe mich
alles wundervoll
irgendwie ist die höhle ein bisschen
komisch oder ab und jeder seite kommen
zahlreiche monster dieser komplette gang
hier dieser schacht ist halboffen weil
der halbinsel schlucht brennen liegt die
können wenn wir wollten zu jeder zeit
raus was ja irgendwie auch den flair
einer höhle kaputt macht aber wenn ihr
zum beispiel mal hier hoch schaut das
ist halt die die oberwelt war sie also
es ist halt gerade nach deswegen sieht
man sich so richtig aber wir können wenn
wir wollten jederzeit raus und das nimmt
ihnen die auch den charme so ein
bisschen von seiner höhle
ich mag gar nicht nach oben immer runter
der effekt wir
haben dennoch das problem dass sich halt
wirklich mein gott komme ich mal
[Musik]
es ist schon
ein bisschen leute gerade jetzt hier und
leute treiben
das kannst du doch nicht ausdenken oder
habe ich ihnen den krieg abo
abgeschlossen oder was
jetzt kann ich hier einfach meine fehler
ein donnern und die alle töten
ich finde ich ja auch noch eine
perfekte grad 15 minuten lang zuschauer
vor der tür gehabt
ich bin so froh dass ich bald wieder
nach köln ziehen
rad wieder reinheit der instant wieder
abgeschossen von hier vorne also dass
man ihnen geprüft wird
ich bin nicht der schlechteste spieler
der welt und leute tier hat schillig
bruder schönen guten tag versteckt sich
da vorne da der ecke kein problem soll
ich jetzt einfach rein ins verderben
hier vorne immer eben ganz kurz töten
wir müssen wirklich einfach in höhlen so
vorgehen dass ganzer körper muss in
höhlen einfach so vorgehen dass man sich
entspannt musik an macht so ein bisschen
hier zwei gehört das ja schon und dann
einfach durch waschen dann ist man
erfolgreich man fürchtet sich nicht vor
irgendwelchen monstern und alles ist
isio ich habe das gefühl dass die
monster dann einfach respekt vor allem
haben und sich denken mensch da tauchen
wir erst gar nicht auf und daher weiter
hier durch die höhle ich brauch mal ganz
kurz hier eben die lava zu dann haben
wir ein bisschen entspannter hier vorne
geht es nur nach oben das wollen wir
nicht wir wollen noch in der höhle
erstmal ein bisschen drin bleiben können
allerdings jetzt erst mal ganz kurz
warten bis die lava hier weg ist um dann
zu schauen was sich unten überhaupt
befindet ich sehe dort vorne auf jeden
fall schon mal ein bisschen gold was wir
mitnehmen können also erstmal hier so
ein bisschen ausleuchten hier das gold
natürlich abbauen ich weiß immer nie
wofür wir das ganze gold gebrauchen
brauchen dann irgendwann aber vielleicht
könnt ihr mir das ja auch und in die
kommentare und hier geht es allerdings
auch schon wieder nach oben hier fordern
wir noch ein bisschen lava und auch gold
das können wir auch nochmal ganz fix
eben abbauen das ist halt relativ selten
deswegen denke ich mir halt immer mensch
wie man mitnehmen bevor ich nicht
mitnehmen allerdings habe ich keine
ahnung wo früher das gebrauchen können
da war kommt die forderung aus die lasse
ich jetzt erst mal und wir befinden uns
in einem neuen gang ich dachte dass wenn
diamanten ist allerdings auch wieder
gold ich muss jetzt einfach mal dass
spinnen auge hier weg und eben auch ich
auch nicht an denen wir hier vorne noch
mal eben fix in
dem ich die lava mit sondern das gold
meine ich und dann gehen wir jetzt mal
wieder hoch zu unserem kleinen aber
feinen schacht hier vorne die wache ist
allerdings dass ich den er jetzt mehr
oder weniger schon zuende entdeckt habe
hiergegen keine einzige richtung meer
also hier ging es da nur hier vorne lang
und hier werden wir auch schon überall
die links ging es dann glaube ich nach
oben genau da hinten hier vorne ging es
gar nicht weiter lang und sonst kommen
wir an der stelle hier auch einfach nur
wieder zurück da wo wir hergekommen sind
von daher würde ich sagen gehen wieder
zurück in unsere höhle und sind jetzt
nun auch wieder hier in diesem raum
angelangt wo wir vorhin auch ausgekommen
sind hier vorne ist nur wieder eine
schlucht wir können hier unten noch mal
eben kurz ins schwimmen und gucken ob
wir hier eventuell noch irgendwelche
diamanten sehen und waren wir allerdings
schon von daher würde ich sagen ich
fühle mich einfach wieder zurück in
unserem raum rein und wir erkunden die
höhle weiter denn hier oben haben ja zum
beispiel auch noch nicht so richtig da
haben wir auch direkt schon wieder nicht
im netz
auch weiter
aber hier geht der gang nämlich auch
noch weiter der schacht
aber jetzt sind wir wieder hier wo
wo ich schon war aber hier jetzt auch
noch lang
es gibt
definitiv viele verschiedene verwinkelte
ecken hier ich möchte allerdings ehrlich
gesagt erst mal die höhle weiter zu ende
entdecken
perfekt direkt wieder ein skelett hier
vorderen staat deswegen augen direkt das
nächste ist auch tot deswegen laufen wir
jetzt erstmal vorne wieder ein bisschen
weiter lang geben weil in diese richtung
ich glaube spielt hawke ich war noch nie
in einer höhle in minecraft in der ich
so wenig orientierung hatte weil es in
jede richtung weitergeht ich habe keine
ahnung wo ich schon war wo ich hin
laufen muss ich glaube hier waren wir
noch nicht das ist unser ausgang
ich bin auch ganz ehrlich
ich glaube ich gehe auch noch draußen
das ist irgendwie keine höhle so wie ich
sie mir vorgestellt habe das mag jetzt
vielleicht klingen mag das vielleicht
auch ein bisschen feige klingen dass ich
jetzt sage ich gehe hier nach draußen
und beende die heutige höhen expedition
die sache ist allerdings dass wir gar
keine form von orientierung uns
aufgebaut haben die höhle hat tausende
ecken wir haben die wichtigen erz die
wir gefunden haben abgebaut werden das
ist
hey
[Musik]
spawnen in der
wüste andere zombie
andere zombie arten als in anderen
millionen das sind doch sowieso da
das habe ich denn jetzt ich habe hunger
mit vier sekunden
wir haben den kollegen von uns am start
wieder der handelnde händler der der was
absolut keine ahnung warum wir uns
gerade hier heimsucht allerdings wenn
wir mal ganz kurz schauen was er so für
angebote am start hat und zwar hat er
eine nautilus schale er hat maiglöckchen
einen roten pilz einen schwarzen
gesetzlich orangen farbstoff und pop
soul nichts davon benötigen wir so
richtig von daher schwimmen bruder mal
ruhig ein bisschen weiter ich würde
sagen meine lieben freunde hier noch mal
ganz kurz die items hier vorne und dass
wir hier die wichtigsten sachen
mitnehmen können und die anderen sachen
einfach dann hier dies wollen lassen
können denn beispielsweise
granit an die sieg oder anderen
benutzten bogen benötige ich nicht
kräftig table habe ich auch noch genug
ich nehme jetzt mal ganz fix meinen com
passiert so dass wir wissen wo wir
hinfahren müssen setze mich hier vorne
in mein brötchen und dann euch doch mal
eine allerletzte tipps für heute in der
wir zurück nach hause fahren werden
[Musik]
und da sind wir auch schon wieder zu
hause in unserer kleinen los locos
insellandschaft angekommen wir sind
recht ein leuchtturm ihr das portal
schwert wir den ballon himmel wir sehen
hinten das los locos schild was ich
jetzt langsam hinter unserer kirche
aufbaut auf der trauminsel und meine
lieben freunde ich habe schon ein
bisschen schiss vor dem ende dieses
projekts wir befinden uns nur noch
wenige folgen verfolge 100 die folge in
der ich dann wahrscheinlich hoffentlich
in cent geben werde und so ein bisschen
gucken werde dass das ganze game
hierdurch spiele der leuchtturm dass ich
wirklich sehr sehr geil aus ich bin froh
darüber war alles was wir geschafft
haben ich hoffe euch darauf dass es euch
heute mal wieder gefallen hat obwohl wir
nichts gebaut haben sondern eigentlich
nur in die höhe gegangen sondern uns die
ein bisschen genauer angeschaut haben
und ich bin ganz ehrlich wir konnten
definitiv feststellen dass die hürde
doch nicht so krass ist wie wir gedacht
haben ich hoffe dass ich heute die
episode minecraft mit luca dennoch
eventuell gefallen hat meine lieben
freunde ich werde hier vorne jetzt noch
mal eben kurz ein bisschen sachen
reinpacken die ich hier schmelzen kann
so dass wir das eisen usw in der
nächsten folge hier auch direkt wieder
rausnehmen können da war auch noch ein
bisschen glatt das anstellen dann packe
ich mal ganz kurz eben in meiner sand
und kies kiste denn das ist ja hier
vorne der fall genau und die restliche
kohle auch noch zurück hier rein und
daher meine lieben freunde an der stelle
würde ich die heutige episode minecraft
mit luca jetzt auch beenden wenn es euch
gefallen hat wie bereits gesagt dass
gerne einen daumen hoch unter video
abonnieren kanal und klickt auf die
glocke wer den noch kleinen teil der
lupo seite schreibt schreibt
in die kommentare was in der nächsten
folge machen soll hat überlegt eventuell
die strandhaus villa komplett fertig zu
stellen also dass in theorie ich kann
nicht reden also das interior
fertigzumachen inneneinrichtungen
schlafzimmer wohnzimmer und so weiter
und so fort soll ich das machen schreibt
und in die kommentare wenn ihr andere
ideen ab schreibt auch gerne in die
kommentare wir sehen uns morgen
[Musik]